et l'albanie est bien en albanie cette
journée de samedi est réputé avoir été
calme
même les observateurs yougoslave qui
affirme et hier soir que l'état
d'urgence était décrété en albanie eh
bien on rectifier leurs propos
aujourd'hui
reste que nous attendons toujours de
pouvoir vérifier sur place que ce petit
pays marxiste léniniste demeure à
l'écart de la révolution politique qui
secoue l'europe de l'est nous avons
tenté ce soir de faire le point sur la
situation en albanie avec laurence
wittner mais aussi à la frontière albano
yougoslave avec la correspondance de
nicolas miletitch aux côtes en fin
d'après midi à la frontière du gréement
elle pèse macédoine à 130km le débris du
res l'avons pratiqué n'avoir rien
observé d'inhabituel du côté albanais à
côté du front s'est tranquillement
manifestement peu préoccupé par les
informations alarmantes de la veille par
les médias us lawe au caire
hier soir déjà le journal de la
télévision albanaise nous montrer des
images de la capitale tirana calme et
tranquille les forces de police dansant
dans la rue et les jeunes recrues de
l'armée en exercice à la fin du
reportage le secrétaire du comité
central du parti photo camille dénonce
fait exceptionnel dans une interview les
inventions et les mensonges de la presse
étrangère pour lui une campagne de
désinformation est organisé pour que se
produise en albanie ce qui vient de se
passer dans les pays de l'est mais aucun
amalgame n'est possible l'ambassade
albanaise à paris nous l'a réaffirmé
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas comparer le
régime albanais à celui de ceausescu la
population libre indépendante et
souveraine soutient totalement les
dirigeants du pays
elle a été nous dit oh époustouflé l
écoute des informations de l'étranger de
son côté l'ambassade de france en
albanie que nous avons contactés par
téléphone cet après-midi affirme que
tout est normal
à tirana voilà ce qu'il faut encore
savoir de l'actualité aujourd'hui à
l'étranger en bref jean paul girouard
les républiques soviétiques du caucase
en ébullition le nagorny karabakh serait
en état de guerre civile l'armée
soviétique tentent de contenir des
affrontements armés opposant azéri et
arménien qui se disputent la
prépondérance politique sur ce
territoire
pas de bilan précis tout comme dans la
république voisine d'azerbaïdjan l'agent
stassi annonce des désordres et des
morts sans plus de précisions
l'azerbaïdjan est elle aussi en proie à
une vive tension nationalistes depuis
quelques jours quatre membres de l'ira
l'armée républicaine irlandaise piéger
en floride
il cherchait à acheter des missiles sol
air stinger et des explosifs
seulement au moment de conclure le
marché ils ont eu la désagréable
surprise de s'apercevoir que leurs
contacts étaient en fait des policiers
huit baies avec ou sans rapport irlande
du nord suite
trois hommes ont été abattus par des
soldats en civil à belfast selon la
police locale ils étaient en train de
commettre un hold up pour le shin payne
la branche politique de l'ira
il s'agit d'un assassinat délibéré mais
paradoxe le chine fine ni que ces sommes
soient des leurs jean paul ii a reçu
aujourd'hui les voeux du corps
diplomatique
l'occasion pour le saint-père d'exprimer
en détaille sa vision des récents
bouleversements qu'a connus la planète
il a rendu hommage aux peuples qui ont
entrepris leur marche vers la liberté en
europe de l'est mais en les mettant en
garde contre tout nationalisme exacerbé
voudrait en france la politique retrouve
de la vigueur en ce début d'année nous
verrons tout à l'heure le débat à
l'intérieur du rpr mais tout de suite la
montée en pression des socialistes à
deux mois du congrès de rennes le comité
directeur de ce week-end est déterminant
notre invité henri emmanuelli l'actuel
numéro deux du ps est là pour me dire ce
qu'il faut penser de l'âpreté de la
lutte pour le pouvoir
et pourtant en est ce matin michel
rocard prenez le calme
en invitant les socialistes à ne pas
tomber dans les querelles de personnes à
défaut du rassemblement immédiat il faut
au moins que chacun fasse preuve de
responsabilité a déclaré le premier
ministre alors tout de suite le point
sur sept premiers jours première journée
de travail au ps daniel sportive
la seule surprise de ce comité directeur
qui confirme la rupture entre laurent
fabius et lionel jospin est venue de
louis mermaz le président du groupe
socialiste à l'assemblée qui prévoyait
de soumettre sa motion au vote des
militants a déposé les armes et rallier
le tandem jospin mauroy il risquait de
ne pas atteindre la barre fatidique des
5% des votes au congrès ce qui lui a
enlevé toute chance d'être représentés à
la direction du parti
satisfaction bien évidente chez pierre
mauroy qui voit un de ceux qui lui
disputent son poste rentré dans le rang
et sourire aussi chez lionel jospin
après le ralliement de ceux
mitterrandiste historique qui redonne un
semblant de vie au courant
mitterrandiste bien mal en point
jean poperen et laurent fabius manquent
toujours à l'appel
ils présentent leur motion au vote des
militants pour laurent fabius la pilule
est amère après le ralliement de louis
mermaz ils risquent d'apparaître comme
celui qui a fêté chou est la synthèse à
ce comité directeur décisif
mais le chef de l'état n'at-il pas
déclaré qu'il n'y a rien de choquant à
ce que les militants se détermine en
fonction des textes qui leur sont soumis
laurent fabius
at il pris cette phrase pour un
acquiescement écouter ce qu'il répond
non sans humour quand on lui demande
s'il brigue la direction du parti
c'était cet après midi au comité
directeur du ps
je vais pas répondre à cette question
commandée dans le bébête show l'avenir
appartient à dieu
alors henri emmanuelli se laurent fabius
en chemise verte col ouvert c'est
l'homme à abattre pour vous ce soir
n'aura goûté il n'y a pas de dôme à
battre pour moi parmi les socialistes
c'est vrai que la particularité cette
fois ci c'est que le courant
mitterrandiste et homme qui peut diviser
mais en fait c'est vrai aussi que la
nouveauté depuis hier soir c'est que
quand même moi je considère que
l'essentiel du courant mitterrandie
s'est reconstitué et qui a la une
dynamique de rassemblement qui je
l'espère n'est qu'un début
j'ajoute que ça fait 18 ans que les
socialistes sont habitués à débattre à
la veille de leur congrès ça n'est quand
même pas une nouveauté il n'y a pas
d'homme un bac mais voulait pas même la
synthèse est ce que pour évincer laurent
fabius vous seriez prêt à faire de
nouvelles d'alliance pense notamment à
michel rocard qui veut lui aussi la
santé has in a déclaré moi je suis
partisan avec pierre mauroy avec de la
jospin avec we mermaz avec michel
delbarre avec henri là et avec beaucoup
d'autres c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours
quelques difficultés à avoir le débat
réduit comme ça sans qu'un ou deux noms
est encore bon et beaucoup d'autres
encore humala faudrait citer tous un
jouet en jachère il a quand même encore
de caen ce soir au moins deux camps les
murs finlande mike crise on est il ya
beaucoup de monde quoi on va pas citer
tout le monde
moi je constate que les choses évoluent
et il n'y a pas d'homme à battre encore
une fois je pense que le parti
socialiste a besoin d'un axe majoritaire
pour assurer sa cohérence sa stabilité
et dont une très grande mesure son
efficacité des vis-à-vis du gouvernement
il est en particulier vis-à-vis du
gouvernement je veux dire plus le parti
socialiste est cohérent et stable
puis il est efficace et mieux il est
entendu par le gouvernement
si besoin ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas donc je souhaite que ce processus de
rassemblement qui est entamée se
poursuivent et que laurent fabius
réfléchissent encore eu encore le temps
avant peut-être de prendre la
responsabilité de recourir à un vote
parce que j'écoutais des allusions
faites bien sûr qu'un vote ça n'est pas
dangereux
enfin votre ca sépare on n'a quand même
jamais vu qu'on se rassembler par un
vote quoi justement parliez tout à
l'heure du gouvernement dans l'accord
mauroy jocelyn merlen est ce que vous
n'avez pas peur d'être un peu taxé de
manque d'indépendance entre guillemets
par rapport au gouvernement
mais pourquoi ça parce que vous avez le
sentiment que leur masse moi même c'est
parti sur les autres sur tout et aux
contributions il ya des ministres et pas
des moindres je pense à pierre bérégovoy
michel charasse non je crois que tout le
monde est dans le bain pour répondre à
votre question par rapport au premier
ministre moi j'ai toujours souhaité
qu'il y ait d'abord le rassemblement des
mitterrandistes est ensuite bien entendu
que le parti se rassemblent comme il
sait le faire ayant renoncé congrès mais
vrai moi qu'il faut une logique une des
mares de deux mois 1
il nous reste deux mois et a ouvert un
débat fraternel
merci en face en face au rpr et bien la
tempête déclenchée par le tandem pasqua
ce gain a été soumise aujourd'hui à
paris à l'appréciation des délégués
régionaux et départementaux du
rassemblement jacques chirac a pris la
base à témoins cet après midi charles
pasqua a dû se déterminer très
clairement lors d'un nouveau bras de fer
le sénateur des hauts-de-seine a
maintenu sa motion chacun reste donc sur
ses positions
eric pierrot les responsables
départementaux du rpr sont maussades
après deux heures de réunion la crise
est loin d'être réglée charles pasqua a
pu s'exprimer certes son discours et sa
faconde commençait même à détendre les
militants quand il a été sèchement
interrompu par jacques chirac
pas de dérision pas de comédie lui a
lancé le président du rpr nous avons un
problème politique alors expliquons nous
charles pasqua a pu poursuivre mais le
débat n'a pas eu lieu
jacques chirac et alain juppé ont voulu
pousser charles pasqua dans ses
retranchements désormais à charles
pasqua de se déterminer
la balle est dans son camp faut-il oui
ou non sur les idées que nous avons en
commun participer deux ouvertures
contraire prêt pour proposer au
rassemblement une autre orientation une
autre ligne
non au commandement il a tout le loisir
bien entendu la réponse de charles
pasqua est clair il défendra sa motion
jusqu'au congrès devant les militants de
faiblir et vous irez jusqu'au bout parce
que j'ai l'air de faiblir
chirac et juppé d'un côté pasqua et ses
gains de l'autre vont prendre la semaine
prochaine leur bâton de pèlerin pour
faire campagne auprès des militants
objectif gagner le congrès le 11 février
au soir
voilà donc pour la politique de ce
samedi il y a tout juste un an à vaujany
près de l'alpe d'huez la cabine d'un
téléphérique se décrochait au cours des
essais préalables à sa mise en service
huit techniciens avaient trouvé la mort
dans cette catastrophe
aujourd'hui le téléphérique que
fonctionne avec les mêmes installations
ce qui inquiète passablement les
habitants du village d'autant que l'
enquête judiciaire n'a toujours pas
donné de résultat concret à faire 3
alpes
jérôme didier ce village de l'oise en
théâtre de cette tragédie on n'a pas
oublié ce vendredi 13 est depuis un an
il flotte à vaujany un certain malaise
c'est un malaise mais pour pour les
habitants de vaujany et pour moi même
mais le conseil municipal de c'est un
malaise que les familles des victimes
ressentent à des degrés différents
surtout quand elle assiste impuissante à
la remise en état des installations en
dépit d'un rapport d'expertisé du
ministère des transports accablant pour
le constructeur
un rapport qui est indiqué dans ses
conclusions erreurs de conception
technique or depuis un an
la justice n'est toujours pas et culte
et
pour nous c'est le vide complet on se
demande qu'est ce qui justifie la
lenteur de la justice et on voudrait
croire quand même que la justice existe
depuis un an approcher un cadre où le
pdg de la société relève de l'exploit
motif invoqué l' enquête est toujours en
cours d'instruction par contre 7 au
grand jour et sans aucun scrupule que
les essais se poursuivent depuis le 2
novembre
et en ce 13 janvier soit un an jour pour
jour après cette tragédie
on est fin prêt pour se lancer à
l'assaut des cimes si tu te suit le tour
de france de l'actualité grâce aux
images de nos stations régionales au
tour de france préparait qu'augmenter
par sophie ni daniel hechter jette
l'épongé
l'inde il quittera très
vraisemblablement la présidence du
racing club de strasbourg après avoir
rencontré roger bambuck j'ai des choses
à lui dire a précisé le couturier
parisien hier daniel hechter avait
récusé l'expertise-comptable qui
faisaient état de 90 millions de déficit
pour le club de football la mairie de
strasbourg à elle affirmé que les
chiffres étaient incontestables
mort mystérieuse à uxeau nié dans les
vosges un corps à demi calciné a été
découvert dans les champs qui agirait de
werner poste un allemand de francfort
qui avait disparu de chez lui depuis un
mois les gendarmes penchent pour un
suicide mais la famille refuse cette
hypothèse une information judiciaire est
en cours
la vallée des camisards ne veut pas
mourir ce site des cévennes et en a fait
menacer par le projet du barrage de la
borie qui engloutirait sous les eaux
aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont manifesté à nîmes pour
rappeler leur opposition au projet cela
à la veille de la clôture d'une enquête
hydraulique qui doit examiner des
solutions de remplacement
apocalypse now dans le haut var depuis
quelques jours nil 400 marines
américains ont investi qu'en juillet
pour parfaire leur entraînement
embuscade combats de rue attaque
héliportée tous les ingrédients du bon
film de guerre sont réunis fils dimanche
que les walkyries de wagner
c'est beau c'est grand le rapport du
tiercé qui se courait cet après midi à
vincennes
il fallait jouer le 6 le 5 et le 18 il
rapporte 900 francs dans l'ordre et puis
pour les heureux qui ont aussi prévu que
le dise arriverait 4e et bien le quarté
+ rapporte dans l'ordre exact d'arrivée
6854 francs quarté + 6 5 10 8 et 10 ce
soir sur la chaîne à 20h35
sam dynamite à 21h50 le soir 3 les infos
présentée par me guy gilbert à 22h15 le
divan d'henri chapier sur lequel ne
s'allongent ce soir irina ionesco une
photographe d'origine roumaine et puis
n'oubliez pas à 23h40
sports3 avec du volley ball voilà la
soirée complète de l'a3 tout de suite la
météo de votre dimanche présenté par
florence klein merci bonsoir très bonne
soirée sur fr3 bon ça
m
et
son combat